and here they are the man of the year
then the straight guy Mads Mikkelsen
German actor Daniel Bruhl and veteran
singer Tom Jones plus yours truly
euromax reporter Hendrick Valley
although strangely are not among the
winners but why what do I need to have
to become man of the year perhaps I can
get some tips from the jury taken from
the editorial team at the german edition
of man's lifestyle magazine GQ given the
amenities Ava's once a year we celebrate
men who have achieved something special
over the last 12 months Landrieu also in
general bring a bit of style to their
field of activity bus teen [ __ ] I don't
fist you give out samira category so our
2015 top dogs alpha males or more the
nice guy next door macho or metrosexual
these days one and three in Germany are
unsure how to present themselves to
women our beards out must let's begin
it's enough to make you one ever lie
down and consult a shrink but back in
the real world what do people on the
streets of Berlin reckon makes a man he
has to be nice cool smart sue Fallon
reliable cut up the strong character he
has to be elegans fateful sense of humor
teeth clip in French we would say gallo
I'd empathetic I guess strong charming
sure of themselves make good money
myristic a man a real man and to
discover the real man in me I go to see
John Eichner professional personal coach
for men technique getting the subject to
confront himself literally cliched
categories of men play only a secondary
role that was a Thesz airfield damn it's
a major factor is being your own man and
having self-confidence being a man with
a feeling of freedom and a bit of a wild
side yeah a man who wants to go out and
have an adventure boy album toya so you
she John has me assume a range of
postures in front of the mirror
according to his theory your poses
linked to yourself awareness capas para
kitna awesome body language goes inward
and outward so you can use it you might
want to have your legs a little further
apart your hands out of your pockets
right in terms of body language we're a
new man something visit us for me it's
like wearing armor you know exactly and
the important thing is you feel that you
feel it from the inside that's good from
in that field and need to look a bit
meaner I was in yeah go for it Oh piss
off
back to the red carpet a GQ Man of the
Year gala and now I see if it also works
on the red carpet where the
photographers and camera teams notice me
could you imagine me as one of the men
of the year
it was funny to walk the red carpet but
to be honest it was very hard to get the
attention of the photographers and it
was Tom Jones in the red carpet maybe I
should get some advice from the ones who
ought to know if you want to be if you
want to become a man of the year like I
am then you have to sing but I can't
sing well then you have to do something
else you have to be true to yourself
first you have to believe in yourself
and I think if you do confidences is
very important I think if you're
confident within yourself it shows it
spits a movie it's important for men not
to take themselves too seriously and I'd
always be proving their masculinity
missing it should be a manner very
gentle two women very kind to women not
all of them are kind to women are you
sure I think you're doing pretty well
you're wearing a tuxedo and your boat is
fairly straight that's a good start yeah
we shouldn't listen to that we should be
who we are and in the end of the day
hopefully that's enough I think a man
has to be a gentleman and I think he has
to be hardworking and passionate about
what he does but also a man who gives
back the man of the year even if I don't
get a price I remain true to myself and
displays self-confidence I'm sure that
puts me close to being a man of the year